i wanna i wanna ask you uh going back to
the fourth turnings we're talking about
the potential conflict now we're getting
into the china war stuff
there's a recent report that the the
pentagon has begun buying bombs
for weapons for use in pacific warfare
as opposed to middle east middle eastern
warfare
we saw a report that the us air force
started spreading out
its uh its resources to various islands
throughout the pacific because they were
concerned about single points of failure
and this was reported as being in
preparation for
a strike from china then we get china
sending 28 warplanes the most they've
ever done into taiwanese defensive
airspace
then we get as an aside sort of uh the
russian war games west of hawaii
and i'm wondering if in your face by the
way
right right right in your face but
here's here's here's what here's what
i'm thinking
the us making these moves we're watching
that happen certainly other things have
happened
in this conflict that we wouldn't know
about before got to this point right
i guess i'm wondering if these physical
and overt signs we're seeing from the
chinese strike groups in the taiwan
strait these warplanes
to the us making these moves are signs
that it's become
so obvious war is coming they're making
moves in our face
so i said back on breitbart radio in 15
when they had the problem with
japan and remember they cut the rare
earths off no yeah yeah they cut
so japan they had a problem with the in
the east china sea with with fishing
trawlers and
fishing i think it was and the chinese
cut japan off of rare earth which means
no semiconductor business no electronics
business
and i said the time the japanese worked
it out okay kind of kowtowed and they
worked it out
and i said about these islands are
coming up these artificial islands
that within five to eight years if we
don't stop these guys now with
information economic warfare we're going
to be in a shooting war in the south
china i patrolled the south china sea as
a young naval officer the south china
sea is the most important
body of water in the world it connects
the persian gulf
straits of malacca with all the markets
throughout asia it's central to the
american economy and quite frankly
silicon valley west whether you have a a
you think you have a moral obligation to
defend the free chinese in taiwan
you've even if you don't think you have
a moral obligation to defend the
judeo-christian west
you have a hard economic interest that's
silicon valley west
all of our advanced chip designers right
there we have to defend taiwan and we're
being
our backs being put up by the feckless
nature
of our elites let me just tell you this
whole concept of the thucydides trap
okay this is a concept that the elites
believe henry kissinger who's juan
shishan's best friend right the real
hatchet man in china
that throughout history like spar sparta
in athens you've had 15 times you had a
declining power
and a rising power and you know 12 of
the 15 times have been a global
conflict but if the elites of the
declining power are smart you can kind
of nudge the rising power in there and
you get them to
to to to to live i heard that it was um
jake sullivan said after we wanted 16
one of the things he was telling people
i think fareed zakar told me this that
that he had said hey the one thing that
bannon got right in this thing
is that uh we're not the declining power
right
we're in decline by our managed release
but we have all the cards right now we
have the capital markets we have access
to
the dollar we have access to our
technology you know she when when trump
negotiated the big
deal the lighthouse deal in 19 the
spring of 19 that huge deal with the
seven verticals that that
that navarre talk about and she and wan
shi shan
reviewed that deal in in april of may
and came back and said deal off
not doing it well the deal was basically
it would restructure chinese economy to
bring it into the to the world it would
stop their state-owned industries and
really destroy the slave labor and make
the whole
this deal was the best deal we would
ever get with the chinese to integrate
them into the world economy
the lighthouse and navarre negotiated it
the chinese reviewed it lee hub was the
guy they went back and looked at it and
they said
you know upon further review this is a
port treaty if we do this we will always
be subservient to the west and we're not
going to do it
he told people internally we are 20
years still behind the west we have to
steal most of the stuff
so we have to expedite this we have to
get on a five-year program
because we're at war with these guys and
we're either going to cow town to them
or we're going to be able to stand up
and we're going to be able to dictate
the terms and that's in the spring in 19
is when this is remember
uh so many smart people have said this
is that geopolitically the most
important thing they actually talked
about technologically decoupling from
america
that their own they would build their
they would have their own amazons and
their own googles and they were technic
they would not be
they would not be for our chip design
and all the advanced
engineering that we do that they still
need they said we're going to get all
off of this because we still count out
to the west so does that spring
of 19 is one of the biggest inflection
points in this conflict
right and everything biden's doing today
is all just this just all happy talks
you saw the meeting with uh blinken
where china said you're not in a
position of strength you know
you are not coming to us from from a
position of strength so i guess just to
reiterate um you mentioned
we may come to the point with the
kinetic war
let's talk about the military meeting
because they're all about face and
formality
tony blanken had you know by the way
he's totally compromised he was part of
the university of pennsylvania and
harvard and these things jake sullivan
taking money
left and right from the chinese
communist party to fund these ivy league
universities it's a disgrace and i say
that somebody's a harvard graduate
it's a disgrace you're taking blood
money from lao beijing from the
the money doesn't come for free it comes
off the sweat of the china the decent
some of the most decent people on this
earth
that's where the money comes from the
criminal class on wall street that's in
business with them
and the universities to take that money
blinking reads this little two-minute
formal thing tyga yang
sits there for 20 minutes and lectures
him you're not telling us what to do
you have no moral authority what to do
and the reason they're evil lecturers
they don't
fear our elites they don't fear our
elites
and that i'm telling you symbolically
throughout the world everybody took
notice of that
because the by administration what he
should have done is said hey thank you
very much you should have called biting
by and said get the plane on and come
home
no more meeting no more talk this is the
humiliation of the west they know our
elites are
feckless they know they're weak and more
importantly
they know that they're bought in we're a
tributary state right now
we ship the trade deficit this year is
going to be a trillion dollars
we're financing their military we're
financing their attack on us
well here's what happens we ship over
raw materials and beef and soybeans and
timber
and coal and and and oil and all that
and they ship back
advanced manufacturing products that
should be here in the united states of
america and guess what they may cost a
little bit
is that the end of the world is the end
of the world that this thing's going to
cost a little bit more is the end of the
world of the product if you've got
good paying jobs and families with good
paying jobs right
and the wife if she doesn't want to
doesn't have to work we can sit home and
raise three four or five kids
okay is that cr is there some law of
physics that says
that it's it's terrible to have to pay
more for products no it is not if wages
rise
this is the central dilemma our elites
are compromised they're weak
and our enemy the biggest existential
threat we've ever had in the nation's
history
understands that they're weak and
feckless and understands they've been
bought and compromised you so you've
mentioned their compromise is it
possible then that they're
just fumbling on purpose so that we
avoid thucydides trap and china just
kind of wedges their way in and we
falter
i think it's i think it's not fumbling
on purpose i think it's part of the they
don't want to confront anybody look at
kendrick henry chris is now warning us
about a cold war we're not in a cold war
war is three parts as they tell us in
unrestricted warfare you have an
information part cyber and an economic
part in kinetic
they're at hot war with us on
information warfare and cyber
they're at a hot war with us on
economics okay that is a hot not a cold
war that's a hot war
thank god we haven't slipped to the
inexorably slipped to the kinetic war
you know why his who's going to pay for
it the kids are the people in my
destroyer were all
working-class people that's is going to
pay for it the same
people that are buried in every patriot
grave in every battlefield throughout
the world
okay in world war one in world war ii in
vietnam and korea the same
working-class people who who thanklessly
and it was thankless okay had to go over
there and take care of all these messes
europe got in
all these messes that communism drove
right
think think of the the quality of
individual that served and dedicated and
went and
fought for this country with no thanks
and don't tell me oh the veterans thank
you for your service
they're gone their futures are gone
their children are gone they were
destroyed crushed
right that's the kinetic world worship
and every veteran knows that
they understand what's those bombers
coming over then when russia
sends a fleet off of the west coast off
of pearl harbor
is doing exercises in what's called the
hawaiian op
area and that's where the u.s navy
transitions the third fleet goes to the
seventh fleet you work up
that the russians are right there
because they're in your face you know
why
they understand our elites are weak and
they will not
push back you wanna you wanna know
something interesting i heard and uh
maybe it's not true but uh i think it's
true
that it exemplifies what you're saying
about the working class being the ones
who go off and die
you know what why smith is the most
common last name
or at least in the west uh so smith
schmidt etc
when wars broke out the smiths wouldn't
go to war
they would stay and make weapons and
when a country was captured the smiths
wouldn't be executed they would
use their knowledge of making weapons to
empower their conquerors so naturally
those last name smith were more likely
to survive
the people who don't go to war
surprisingly the ones who make the
weapons
are the ones who continue to live on and
expand and
i mean no disrespect to anybody named
smith i'm just pointing out that
a lot of people are used for cannon
fodder by the wealthy elites
and the military-industrial complex who
are the modern blacks thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you